die arktis oder umgangssprachlich der
nordpol eisfrei bot das was in der
arktis passiert bleibt nicht auf die
arktis beschränkt diese warnung der
vereinten nationen ist in ihrer
eindringlichkeit nicht mehr zu
überbieten konkret geht es um die
drastische erwärmung der arktis die
demnach schon jetzt nicht mehr zu
verhindern ist und nicht nur das laut
der neuen studie könnte die arktis ab
den 2030er jahren im sommer eisfrei sein
mit gravierenden folgen für die gesamte
erde klicks um science-fiction hier
gibt's täglich faszinierende
wissenschaft silos abonniert den kanal
nur dann verpasst er nicht herzlich
willkommen wir haben die wissenschaft es
ist höchste zeit dass wir jetzt dringend
handeln
denn nur klimaschutzmaßnahmen können
bevorstehende umkehrpunkt abwenden
die für unsere erde viel schlimmere
folgen haben könnten als den bislang
gedacht haben so heißt es von der
stellvertretenden umweltdirektor in der
un klima
damit nimmt sie bezug auf die gerade
veröffentlichte studie des
umweltprogramms der vereinten nationen
unep demnach schmilzt das arktis eis
sehr viel schneller als gedacht um 3 bis
5 grad celsius könnten die
wintertemperaturen in dieser region bis
zur mitte des jahrhunderts ansteigen
schon jetzt liegt die temperatur dort
deutlich über dem langjährigen
durchschnitt und zwar um knapp 3 grad
auf dem rest der erde wurde eine
erwärmung um ungefähr 1 grad
festgestellt der grund dafür dass sich
die arktis stärker als andere regionen
der erde erwärmt liegt fachleuten
zufolge an der sogenannten taktischen
verstärkung im polarmeer und dem
grönländischen eisschild gibt es immer
weniger fläche die von eis bedeckt ist
doch die eisfreien flächen auf land und
im meer reflektieren das sonnenlicht
sehr viel weniger sondern absorbieren
die energie stattdessen so erwärmen sich
der region immer weiter in der
fachsprache wird dieser effekt der
reflektivität als albedo bezeichnet
verstärkt wird dieser effekt durch ruß
und staub die bei waldbränden in
sibirien und kanada entstanden sind und
sich auf dem grönländischen eis ablagern
auch dies führt dazu dass das
sonnenlicht deutlich weniger reflektiert
wird die folgen in der arktis sind schon
jetzt enorm beispielsweise bauen die
permafrostböden die normalerweise
ganzjährig gefroren sind laut einer
langzeitstudie des
alfred-wegener-instituts aus bremerhaven
ist die bodentemperatur zwischen 2007
und 2016 im mittel um 0,3 grad celsius
angestiegen
der untergrund und gibt somit nach und
gefährde die stabilität von straßen und
gebäuden
zudem hat das ganze exklusive folgen für
uns alle und das im wahrsten sinne des
wortes denn durch das tauen der
permafrostböden wird gashydrat frei
das im boden eingelagert ist das gemisch
ist gefroren und besteht aus methan und
wasser wenn es erwärmt wird explodiert
es in sibirien gab es bereits enorme
detonationen von denen riesige krater
zurück bleiben aber auch das erdklima
muss darunter leiden denn das trauen des
permafrosts setzt letztendlich
gigantische mengen an kohlendioxid und
methan frei die zu den langlebigen
treibhausgasen zählen und zur
erderwärmung beitragen konkret nur durch
das town der böden eine große menge
biomasse aus abgestorbenen pflanzen frei
die dann durch boden bakterien zersetzt
wird und bei diesem prozess entsteht
methan und kohlendioxid und das nicht zu
knapp nicht umsonst wird das schmelzen
des permafrosts in der arktis als
sogenannter kipp punkt bezeichnet
rückkopplungseffekte im globalen
klimasystem also die am ende dafür
sorgen dass sich die erwärmung der erde
selbst verstärkt und im schlimmsten fall
dann unumkehrbar wird
und schon jetzt sind folgen deutlich
laut der aktuellen studie der unep hat
sich die arktische meereis fläche in den
letzten 40 jahren also seit 1979 um 40
prozent verringert klimamodelle
prognostizieren dass die arktis in den
sommern ab den 2030er jahren sogar
eisfrei sein wird wahnsinn wenn wir
menschen weiterhin so viele
treibhausgase ausstoßen wie bisher
doch selbst wenn wir eine enorme
erwärmung der arktis schon jetzt nicht
mehr verhindern können liegt es doch in
unserer hand zumindest die spitze des
temperaturanstiegs zu kappen die
aktuellen berechnungen der un zeigen
außerdem dass die eismassen der arktis
zu einem drittel verantwortlich sind für
den anstieg des globalen meeresspiegels
laut der studie könnten allein in den
arktischen gebieten vier millionen
menschen hauptsächlich aus eingeborenen
völkern betroffen sein
doch nicht nur das denn dass der anstieg
des meeresspiegels für die meisten
länder dieser erde fatale folgen haben
wird darüber haben wir hier bei klick
zum science fiction ja schon auf
richtet und als wäre das nicht schon
genug der temperaturanstieg in der
arktis könnte indirekt auch dazu führen
dass bei uns in europa aber auch in
nordamerika und russland extreme
kältewellen drohen denn die luftströmung
des sogenannten polarwirbel schwächt
sich durch die nachlassende eisbedeckung
des polar meeres phasenweise ab das kann
dazu führen dass kalte polare luftmassen
nach süden ziehen da man ja auch schon
öfter darüber berichtet auch darüber und
so warnt auch der finnische
umweltminister kino die league einen die
dringlichkeit die ziele des pariser
abkommen zu erreichen zeigt sich
eindeutig in der arktis denn sie ist
eine der am stärksten gefährdeten und
sich rasch verändernden regionen der
welt wir müssen die
treibhausgasemissionen und andere klima
schadstoffe in der ganzen welt
kurzfristig erheblich reduzieren
ein ergebnis der aktuellen studie macht
eine sache noch einmal extrem deutlich
nämlich dass es nicht nur höchste zeit
ist jetzt zu handeln sondern dabei auch
langfristig zu denken denn selbst wenn
wir ab sofort emissionen einsparen
würden die wintertemperaturen in der
arktis in den nächsten zwei jahrzehnten
ansteigen die folgen der vergangenen
jahre dazu heißt es in der studie
selbst wenn die bestehenden
verpflichtungen des pariser abkommen
erfüllt werden dürfte der angst tische
permafrost im vergleich zu heute um 45
prozent schrumpfen
die fragen liegen auf der hand in
welcher welt wollen wir leben wie wollen
wir unseren nachkommen die erde
überlassen wollen wir das wirklich alles
zu lassen auch die antworten sind klar
friday is for future und so steht fest
schule schwänzen für das klima ist eine
gute sache denn das engagement der
jungen leute hat schon jetzt einiges
bewegt und da hat der frühere
us-präsident barack obama recht den
kampf gegen die klimaerwärmung kann man
nicht zitat den alten leuten überlassen
bei seinem besuch in köln anfang april
sagt der wortwörtlich hier würde teuren
großvater niemals darüber entscheiden
lassen was er anzieht oder welche musik
er euch anhört aber lasst ihn darüber
entscheiden was mit der umwelt geschieht
in der ihr leben werdet ein aufruf also
gegen den klimawandel einzutreten und
sich zu engagieren
schließlich ist der klimawandel nichts
was in 50 jahren stattfindet er
geschieht genau jetzt
klimawandel und co alles manipulation
da geht florian schroeder satirisch an
das thema draufklicken anschauen und
natürlich schröder satire kanal
abonnieren bis dann bleibt dran